the Ukrainian military says that it shot
down more than 60 Russian drones and
cruise missiles on Monday
unconfirmed videos show the roof of a
house demon damaged by the debris caves
Mayer says blast were heard in several
districts it is the second straight
overnight barrage and the 15th attack on
the capital this month let's go to our
correspondent Natasha Butler who's live
for us in Kiev Natasha how has Kiev
coped with this attack from Russia
overnight
I would be editor
look it's very difficult indeed for
people in this city you have Ukrainian
officials saying that Russia launched
some uh more than 70 cruise missiles and
drones across the country overnight uh
Ukrainian officials saying that their
Air Force shot down uh more than 60 of
them 40 alone here over the capital Kiev
so throughout the night it was extremely
noisy we heard explosions as all that
was happening and of course for people
in the city it means that it is very
difficult they are getting exhausted
that though is one of the aims of
Russian forces according to Keith they
say that Russia is looking to try and
grind down the population exert more
psychological uh pressure on people in
Keith as well as to try and knock down
some of its air defenses and knock out
Military targets and we know there's
some military targets were struck by a
cruise missiles particularly in the west
of the country an air military base
there was hit
and what about the Ukrainian counter
offensive how is that going
well what we've seen in the last few
days are Ukrainian forces certainly step
up uh some of their attacks we have seen
uh strikes missile strikes in
russian-occupied parts of the country in
the eastern and South around for example
uh mariopol and what this is what we
know is that this is part of the first
steps if you like the preparations for
Ukraine's counter-offensive in fact we
were told as much by a top advisor to
the Ukrainian president of Vladimir
zielinski just a few days ago he said
this is about softening uh the terrain
if you like before the full
counter-offensive begins and what
Ukrainian forces are doing is targeting
strategic areas military infrastructure
supply lines anything that will help
them in this upcoming counter-offensive
that has been so highly anticipated in
some ways you can say it started in
other ways you can say the full push is
uh still to come either way a lot of
pressure keep a lot of pressure on
Ukraine who will want to show that they
can deliver results particularly to
their Western allies right okay keep
safe Natasha Butler there for us live in
Kiev I have to say that's quite unusual
because most of them
right sorry to interrupt you there
Natasha I think I think uh you go keep
safe for now